Daniel says, I know you talked about 50 and lower on search volume, like 30 or 40.
Yeah, Daniel, he's talking about the base bare minimum search volume.
Guys, what I would say is that I would make sure at this point, and when I do
version 3.0, when that's completed, I'm going to make sure that I'm very, very, very clear about
this. But we're on here live right now. I would make sure it's 50 or above, especially if you're
going after your first deal, because I don't want you guys to get in a situation where you get a
deal, you hook them, or you get the deal, and then the leads kind of dry up, and you don't know how
to navigate around the situation. So for me, if I get in that situation, I already know if I'm
looking at a deal and it's like a 30 volume, 30 search volume, I'm going to tell them up front,
like, hey, this is going to be a fluctuation. I'm going to really sell them hard and let them know
it's going to be a variable volume amount of leads for the first couple of months, because
I just have a feeling, whatever. I'm not going to say that, but I'm going to know.
And I'm going to be able to kind of talk my way through those situations. If it's your first deal,
it can become very scary, and it's like that deal is so important to you. So Daniel, my advice for
you going for that first, second, third deal, go 50 or above. Make it simple.